so let's deal with so again we're I'm
tasking you
with it's martially conceptually or Mar
you know at the level of
concept it is viable and then two it is
also
concentrically energetically true okay
so as he comes to grab me waiting here
is not conceptually
viable as a marshall aspect okay it's
not it so as he moves into what is in
essence is grappling range you see he
has all his stuff
here I can't be waiting here if I if we
stand don't kill me all
right if we stand and he got into that
AR arms arms reached you
see if I stood here such as I'm waiting
I'm actually
contesting his Yang energy and that's
what allows the opening for his
grappling moves so all the way here do
some grappling kind of thing whatever
okay actually do it like you're I'll
kick your [\h__\h] ass if you don't do
something
yes
got
it but if as he goes for that
distance if I'm not there then this
stuff becomes
viable do you understand and I don't
have to be stronger than him which I'm
not
so this is already
wrong as he
moves I'm moving you see
that but I can't go ahead of
it the form is requiring me to get it so
I'm giving it but I'm
not
[Music]
it's just at that sweet
spot
meaning if that is now contesting
it and this is running away from
it I'm right at The Sweet Spot he does
not feel his fingers being stressed
me trying to be ahead of it and nor does
he feel my chest pushing on
him sweet
spot
right the same thing there's a sweet
spot if you want to make it modern
Marshall terms there's a sweet
spot same thing here Sweet
Spot sweet spot
same thing right here there's a sweet
spot sweet spot
okay so you're just
using yin and principle I am
neither Yin nor
y neither contested nor
retreating okay
and then you have the Marshall Sweet
Spot try
it okay the next Marshall concept is
kazushi energetically this ISS that my
center and his Center are in that IE
we're in a relationship my Center is his
Center his Center is my Center okay
martially it's following the rule like I
like I love that Roman Maxim that you
fight the Archer not the
arrow so I'm not interested really in
what his arms are doing I'm interested
in his
body and I watch you to understand
kazushi as that iky relationship between
the centers I don't want you to
understand it as
tilting if you don't have that Center to
Center communion you're not tilting any
anybody that doesn't want to be
tilted not unless you're stronger than
them so like in for example in modern
Judo that's why you have weight
categories because they just do push and
pull
now but if I am controlling his center
it's going to be easy to tilt his
spine in what is today recognized as
Kaz but energetically I'm not establish
in the
tomen so I'm not consistent with my
energetic Concepts and then martially
you find out the hard way you can't push
and pull to tilt stronger people it
doesn't work okay but if I do establish
kazushi it's much easier to push and
pull
someone and if he has a precarious
balance it's much more difficult for him
to
remain with a martial Advantage okay so
I'm doing the first part here where I'm
not
contesting but I am in that connection
here's where I see an
actual iy between the two tonden
fields at the beginning you don't have
it you in a way you are controlling his
Center but it's more in his desire to
grab
you so I'm
out and here now is where I seek the
relationship and it has to be done in a
way that I am going to
get him to
tilt so for example if I go
here I am not going to get him to tilt
into the front inward
kazushi of eel if I
push he's going to do a different
kazushi
pattern so if we look at I need to have
his
energy go past his
hand
here his
hand cannot remain in front of his
body because then when you you push if
you were able to you'd be pushing
against his y energy and if you could
overpower it you'd have him going in a
different kazushi not the E kazushi so I
have to move in a way that his hand is
not in front of his body you guys see
that so I have to take the first
principle not contesting not running
away and put it in a place where his
body passed his hand hand you see
that and when I seek that
relationship martially I'm going to
prioritize physical parts of my
body that do not drain my
energy so I'm going to use anything I
can to conserve energy
that's going to be ground
vectoring that's going to be the claw
and that's going to be the tanden field
so I can maintain that actual kazushi of
Center to Center
communion so we go
boom
here I'm ground vectoring on the back
foot and leg the qua is activated and
the claw can only turn this
far if you go past this you're now
deflating the tonden
field
boom H that's
it here would be something different
waiting Push Pull I'm in front turn my
waist
waiting pulling turn my
waist not waiting past it boom don't
turn your
[Music]
waist
okay
all right second point on this second
Point uh you have to do it all at once
so you can't go here the hands in front
and then go around now the hands in
front okay you got to do it all at once
in I make there it is and there it
is all that once then then it's not
martially conceptually viable
third point on this same thing when you
have a shoulder grab in your Keyon
rituals you
are
cultivating this weak point the corners
of your body are weak point that's why
you have a technique like sumush you
always attack the corners it is the soft
spot of any organization okay you attack
the corners so you're being trained here
on how not to have this be independent
of everything else okay so when you come
around he
[Music]
goes and you see that no no and you're
going to have to now do bigger motion
with your waist to get
it same thing here he goes to push this
do you see no hold it together move
together move
together going to have to learn how
to have his energy generate your tonden
field and then how not to let energy
leakage out of it now
[Music]
one do it differently
no same energetic principles
boom Okay add those two additional
points to this second Point let's go
back a point because now that you are
not allowed to disconnect your shoulder
which would be energetically
incorrect you're contesting the push
okay so let's look at
something you you always in your aido
and again for martially viable reasons
this fight is going to
rotate I'm not going to work going 12
the six and I'm not going to work
here this thing's going to rotate so as
he goes to move I'm always rotating this
fight as he goes to Grapple I always
rotate the
fight you can't do that with let's do
the pugilistic you can't do it here you
can turn in I'm no better shape same
thing he goes to Grapple I can't do it
here this thing has to
rotate and if you look at when my
rotation and how it
starts and let's the strikes as slow as
you can my body is going to turn my body
is going to
turn body turns I don't come
here the quad turns and then I
move we go to
Grapple quaw turns quaw
turning and then I move qua and then
move we got to go slow for this cuz
everyone missed
and not here and going straight
out
no try to find the
turns okay so he goes which way is my
shoulder actually
going forward in forward in okay same
thing if his sword comes I reach for his
sword I reach for his sword and then
yield to his sword let's do the
grappling one I reach for his hands and
then yield to his hands yield to his
hands same thing he goes to strike
there's a slight movement forward and
then yield to it okay
energetically here I'm going to reach
for him and then yield to
it you understand you're doing that in
the whole form but it starts earlier on
so the very beginning let's just go you
guys try spot so
in in around with my body though so
in
straight out
different so there's a it's going to go
in first as I reach for it and then I'm
going to yield for
it
boom and turn and this is how he passes
me so again reach for it around it
turning
so if we're short for example this here
Voom no movement on the
legs here my legs have to do
it there's the
in
turn
in all
in
out but not my waist my body moves qu
moves qu
[Music]
moves
okay let's
go all right the next one is the
projection so again the Marshall viable
concept is that you always project in
the center you that's what actually and
then energetically it's the center
Center
communion that you're trying to utilize
okay so in this case as he comes in and
at that point where I deviate and I'm
out here here is where his tonden is
generated by his Yang energy so that
means it goes into me and it's going to
form the lower tonden field and I keep
that and as it does it in me it'll do it
in him and that's what I move so I know
it looks like I'm just shoving up his
skeleton but that's actually going over
his tonden you see that it's going over
his
tonden and that is no more correct than
when you came in front of his tonden
with that waist turned you see so when
you get to that spot and you feel that
you are look how I dropped you see and I
make I'm making this conten move
and I don't know if you f felt that but
he ended up reaching with his arms which
is the
next um Marshall
concept when you take someone's
tanden and you put it in the kazushi
pattern then and only then do the arms
become
attackable so for
example uh I come in and I'm going to do
a kosa I have the center that's what
makes this arm reach and opens up the
arm bar
combination if you don't take the center
the arms don't reach they remain under
his control and that window of
opportunity is
closed that's what you're doing here
martially so I come
around project his Center that gets the
arm loose and that's what allows for the
go if you're over here and you're in
front of his energy the arm is very much
under his control no
different then if you go straight up the
shoulder everything looks right and
you're straight up there a lot of
control
here find his
Center project his Center that's what
allows the arm to hang out there for you
and of course
energetically this Marine of our two t
Dan is
[Music]
iy let's have this p
go yeah see it shoulder disconnected
don't disconnect the shoulder you're
you're not moving correctly into the
neutral space not Yang not Yin
and you're looking for your shoulder to
give you some extra slack so if you did
not disconnect your shoulder you would
have been Ying his young got it so go
you can't look for that corner Freedom
[Music]
go there's that contestation right there
and then his you went over his Center
that's why his arm didn't get light on
you
you got to get into a center and it's
lower than the
shoulder oops the shoulder you got
pushed you got disconnected at the
corner cuz you're contesting you got to
move for neutral move for
neutral into the center don't get greedy
first project the center and now enter
there you
go remember the Tactical priority is his
Center Center not his arm
right into Center you're over the top of
[Music]
it okay you're you're having to have a
lot of athleticism in your shiko you're
like really traveling across the mat
that is a sign that your timing is off
if your timing is not off
it's very it's minimal movement okay
you're
like timing is off you're
late if you're in the right time it's
very easy so really it's just a one and
that's
it that's it a one that's
it
you see okay otherwise as you get older
you're not going to be able to do it and
then
now you better be faster than your
opponent okay and that's not a good
thing
go okay good
oops a little pressure right and
disconnected that
shoulder okay let's try this side
again
good KN up the arm find the center
Center nope it's
lower
arm lower lower there you
go all the time try to get lower always
try to get lower lower lower lower lower
attack the center from underneath not
not from it direct 90 to the
mat underneath it there you
go okay I'll show you why okay so
remember in
II in iido alchemy you do a pattern in
your rituals with your tanen right and
in that pattern you're going to rotate
the cross in the four cardinal
directions and one of them is up you
have to have a up okay
so as I come around my it went to the
left it's going to go to the
right and here's where it's going to go
up my tanden is going to go up which
means I'm underneath his
tanden my tan is not going to go one way
sideways and then sideways again you see
that so my
tanden
under boom under and
up okay up you got to have the up
element try it
again of course barley that makes sense
[Music]
right
oops start
over
[Music]
so find his Center in the arm you even
though I touch his arm I still am on his
Center yes his arm is now exposed from
the kazushi
okay but when I touch his arm I'm I'm
touching his arm and touching his Center
just like when he was grabbing my
shoulder I am and he's touching me with
his hand I'm touching his Center okay
I'll show
you over
there and you're here and this is loose
there's no Center in that angle yes I
can kind of get him down but it's
violating the Marshall principle that I
want kazushi at all times so I want his
Center so as we're going I don't
care around but see his Center
move
C even if you take that short
angle I'm still going to be you feel
that it's still in his Center
okay don't just stay out on the
periphery of his body organization okay
try